around the world more than 20 million
people are the victims of human
trafficking in las vegas as you may know
has had a problem with human and sex
trafficking for decades throughout
january local advocates are working to
try and raise awareness about the issue
bianca holman is live this morning with
the numbers the statistics and how las
vegas can help bianca good morning
good morning so experts tell us that the
human trafficking industry is about a
100 billion dollar industry and 5
million coming from throughout here in
las vegas and things happening here and
throughout the west coast so we've
learned a lot from experts on what they
tell us what's happening here in las
vegas in regards to human trafficking
and of course january a time to raise
awareness and talk about prevention
efforts that we can do as a community to
prevent this issue from happening across
the valley so traffickers they look for
vulnerabilities to exploit and
manipulate their victims into believing
they have no choice than to do sex acts
or even forced labor like construction
restaurant work or domestic services and
this is all against their will we spoke
with dawn merritt with refuge for women
here in las vegas and she tells us most
people are pulled into this after months
of grooming which can happen through the
internet
if you encounter someone who
never has an id
looks like they're being abused in some
way they won't make eye contact they
seem to be scripted when they're
speaking that could very well be someone
who's being exploited
refuge for women is a non-profit they
help women who've been trafficked get
off the streets and give them tools to
get back to a normal life and during
2021 the group says they served about 22
women in residential housing held more
than 500 support groups in sessions and
they also helped with more than 100
people with financial assistance getting
them back on their feet and giving them
the resources that they need and also
marriage she says that they work with
groups and companies and restaurants and
bars around the valley to help give
employees training on how to recognize
some of those signs of someone who may
be in danger so she says definitely
reach out if you want your business and
your employees to be trained on being
able to recognize and help prevent human
trafficking here in las vegas bianca
holman live local now